when word got out about your injury
people like Wendy Williams were saying
you somehow faked it now it wasn't
people like Wendy Williams it was Wendy
Williams started this rumor which was
stunning to me stunning because I you
know I've been on Wendy's show a few
times and for some reason she liked me
and she would call on me to support her
in tough times so I got a call one day
that she was having a terrible bout of
stage fright and she was about to drop
out of Chicago the musical and would I
come over and talk to her and I was like
you will never meet a more supportive
and loving cast you will love this
experience and you will regret it if you
don't do it and I gave her all the same
advice that I'm giving Sayla right now
don't let the fear you know keep you
from experiencing something go for it
whatever I was there for her then she
goes through a divorce I get a call
again cuz let's face it I'm kind of an
expert
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I guess it's time for a pro to take over
I came again and I you know was like I'm
gonna help you with the lawyers very
important and you know and how to you
know not go back if you really feel you
know and to break and do it and be
strong anyway so I was so I thought it
was a mistake when somebody said she was
doing this I thought you know what I'd
like to do now I want to show Wendy
you'll x-rays okay so so I when I hit my
doctor said most people break one of
those big bones that run you know down
the arm I broke both of them but I
didn't just break them because of the
angle that I hit
they shattered and I don't have
osteoporosis or anything like that I
just hit it the wrong angle that's
almost athletes against a teenager it
happened to me at besides the two bones
shattering I also like apparently
there's a bone that should face this way
and it was facing the opposite way oh
and my surgery that was supposed to take
an hour and a half ended up taking three
hours and they ended up putting a plate
and then that thing that sort of wraps
around the corner and then a whole thing
there and and it's you know it's your
bruise yeah and you know
do you want to send to Wendy yeah I'm
wearing pink okay it's not rubbing off
on me you have a message for Wendy a
message to wendy is it's so much more
fun to be kind yes it can't feel good to
try to hurt other people
that's right can't feel good if it feels
good something seriously wrong yeah you
know and you know like like love more
[Music]